There was a time in the gilded cages of Parisian salons when Wit had a name, Esprit d'Escalier,
the clever remark you only thought of after the door had closed behind you.
The maven, of course, saw it differently, not as a failure of timing, but as a triumph of self-preservation.
By never risking the deep thing, you shielded your fragile ego from the kind of scrutiny that might expose the hollow center of your own existence.
And so, conversation became a trench.
Not a bridge, not a path to connection, but a fortified position where you could stand just close enough to be present, just far enough to remain invisible.
The weather, the traffic, the endless churn of the news these were your weapons.
Safe topics, like safe distances, ensuring no one ever reached the void where your actual self might lurk.
The digital wasteland had taught you well.
The surface was the only place to live.
The illusion of depth was your greatest tool.
Psychologists call it explanatory depth, our delusion that we understand the world better than we do.
The maven weaponized it.